okay so in the last section Sean gave a
great runtime speed-up to the multiple
pattern matching algorithm that we
presented using a try but along the way
he completely forgot about memory so
here's the try that we were working with
for the patterns that we had and you can
verify that the number of edges in this
try is approximately equal to the total
length of combined length of all our
patterns and in fact in the worst case
the number of edges in this in this try
are going to be big-oh of the combined
length of all patterns and this is not
necessarily great because the path the
combined length of patterns may be 40 or
50 times the length of the genome so
that's a huge amount of memory that
we're going to have to use so the
question would be rather than processing
the patterns into a data structure can
we instead flip this around and say can
we process the genome into a data
structure if this data structure used
Big O of the length of genome then that
would be a huge memory reduction and so
Shawn was talking about the idea of
putting all the patterns into a data
structure that he thought about as a bus
so we could move this bus down the
genome in one path and all the patterns
could get off when they found a match
and so to do this data structure that
where we we process the genome as a data
structure instead what we're thinking
about is we're going to ask each pattern
where is it that you want to go okay and
we're going to take the pattern straight
there so we're going to essentially fold
up the road itself fold up the genome
and say and take it to the patterns okay
and so the analogy I thought there is if
each pattern is going to the precise
location in the genome that it needs to
go well this is a transporter right okay
so all nerdiness aside here's what we're
going to do we're going to form all
suffixes of our genome and then the
question would be how is it that we
combine these suffixes into a data
structure the one that we've seen is a
try ok and you may be curious why is it
that we're forming all suffixes of
genome but just bear with me for a
second and you'll see ok so for example
consider this hypothetical genome
panamabananas' and to form the suffix
tri for it notice
first that I've added a dollar sign to
the end of the string alright this you
can just think of this as a notational
thing it's important for a number of
reasons that will that would come up
through the course of this lecture but
from now on we'll just assume that when
we're working with the genome we add a
dollar sign to denote the end of the
string it'll it'll tell us that when
we've hit the end of the string so that
we'll know that we've had a suffix so we
add panamabananas'
to the suffix tri then the next suffix
is anima bananas we add it to the tri
then amma bananas and so on and then we
encounter amma bananas and it starts
with an A which is the same as another
suffix and so we start threading it into
the tree and so on all right so we
create this suffix tri in practice you
probably go from shorter suffixes to
longer suffixes but I've gone the other
direction and then we have the completed
suffix try now if it looks big hold that
thought for a minute right because it
does look very big but now we have a
data structure that has to do with just
the genome right we don't have to
process the patterns into it into a data
structure we have a data structure
that's only on the genome so then we say
how do we use the suffix tri for pattern
matching it may not be clear how it is
that it's going to help us and what
we'll do is remember that when we use
the Tri before we said at each position
of the genome is it possible to spell
down a pattern from the root to a leaf
of the Tri in this case what we're going
to say is let's take each pattern and
see if we can spell out that pattern
from the root down word tool in the
suffix tripe
okay so here's an example here's the
pattern banana and we know that that
occurs in panama bananas and if we start
at the root then we go to B and we can
spell it down this path and we see that
we spell out the entire string banana
and end at this node so what that tells
us is we were able to spell it out in
the suffix try and that means that it
must be a pattern match okay
NAB is a pattern that we know doesn't
occur in panama bananas we can match the
first two letters following this path
but were unable to match the third
letter okay antenna is another pattern
that we know doesn't occur we can match
the first two letters but again not the
third and Nana is one that we know it
appears once so we get to na and then we
walk down the path na to match Nana all
right so you see that the suffix trys is
working for us but the question would be
then where is it that these matches are
we're able to identify that if you go
back to Nana we're able to say it occurs
in the string but this does not
presently give us any information about
where that match occurred in the string
so to find where these pattern matches
are we're going to need to add a little
bit more information to the suffix try
that we have at leaf of the tree we'll
try what we're going to do is we'll add
the starting position of the suffix that
whose path ends at that leaf so when we
walk down the suffix to a leaf will add
the position at the leaf where the
suffix originally started in the genome
so for example if we come back to our
try for panama bananas then the entire
string is a suffix and it starts at
position 0 so here is the path from the
root to a leaf that corresponds to that
suffix so we put a 0 at that leaf for
animal bananas here is the path that
ends at that leaf and so we labeled it
with 1 which is the starting position of
that suffix and so we find each path
through the genome or through the try
corresponding to a suffix and label it
with subsequent integers so 2 3 4 etc ok
and so we can go through and do all this
so now we've added this information so
the question is how is it that this
information is going to help us well
once we found a match we're simply going
to walk down to the leaf to find out
what the position of that match was ok
so for example if we come back to banana
alright we found that banana is a match
and so we simply walk down the remaining
two nodes to the leaf and see that that
is at starting position 6 the suffix
starting with banana was it starting
position 6 so banana must be at starting
positions
six alright another example would be a a
this occurs in three different places in
Panama bananas and so when we found the
match we're not we're nowhere near a
leaf yet in fact we're at a node that
branches okay and so to find the
starting starting position of all
matches of a na we need to walk down
each of these three paths to a leaf so
if we walk down this path we get
starting position one if we walk down
this path we get starting position seven
and if we walk down this path we get
path we get starting position nine so it
tells us that we have three starting
positions one seven and nine notice that
seven and nine the occurrence of a na
overlaps okay and this information tells
us exactly where those patterns matched
the issue though would be that you may
have noticed that the suffix try is
bigger than the original try that we had
for the patterns and in fact in general
it's going to be larger in a worse case
it holds the combined length of all
suffixes but the problem is that if the
genome has length n the combined length
of suffixes is equal to n times n minus
1 over 2 and that term is Big O of N
squared so we're dealing with something
that's now quadratic in the length of
genome and this is not going to be
practical for a real genome I still
think we've got a good idea though and
so what we'll do is compress the tree a
little bit so we will take the suffix
try and compress the information that's
stored in it and maybe we get something
that is a lot smaller so the way that
we'll do this is we're going to take
each non-branching path of the tree so
if we see a path that doesn't split at
all then we are going to be able to
compress that into one edge that
represents the string along that path so
if we come back to our suffix tri here
is a non branching path notice it does
not branch ok and we can compress this
into just a single edge that's labeled
with bananas which was what was labeled
on this path ok and so we can do this
for every non branching path in the in
the suffix tri here is ma bananas and we
compress it into an edge
and sullen now if you were implementing
this in a real program you would
probably use pointers instead of storing
all these strings which would be which
would still consume a lot of memory but
you'll notice as we go through and we do
this compression just visually you can
see how much smaller it's making this
example suffix try and we have one more
compression and we're done so it's much
smaller and then the question it this
data structure is going to be called a
suffix tree okay so we move from a
suffix try to a suffix tree and the
natural question would be exactly how
much memory does the suffix tree hold in
general we know that it's clearly
getting smaller but maybe this is just
some example for any genome that you
would consider the number of nodes is
actually going to be in the suffix tree
will be less than two times the length
of the genome and that's going to be Big
O of genome and if you want to see why
this is notice that the number of leaves
is equal to the length of the genome why
is that well it's because each path from
the root to a leaf corresponds to a
unique suffix and because of that there
are length of genome suffixes
so each there's a one-to-one
correspondence between the leaves in the
suffix tree and the suffixes of the
genome and so there's a the number of
leaves is equal to the length of the
genome what about these internal nodes
well it can be shown that the number of
internal nodes is always less than the
length of the genome so this is going to
give us that the combined number of
nodes is always less than two times
length of the genome so we've now moved
from something that's quadratic whose
memory is quadratic in the length of the
genome to something whose memory is
linear in the length of the genome so
this compression has done a lot for us
and it's what we've wanted to do again
I'll reiterate we we had a suffix try
and we had quadratic memory the issue
would be that now we have a suffix tri
and we have to create it before we can
compress into our suffix tree and so if
we're not able to go directly to our
suffix tree then we still have a problem
because we're can
assuming a lot of memory along the way
even though the memory that we have in
the long run is smaller fortunately
though it turns out that they are like
really magical crazy algorithms that you
can look up that will be able to take
you directly to the suffix tree and will
do so in run time and memory that are
both linear in the length of genome so
we don't have to worry about going
through the suffix try first we can go
straight to the suffix tree and so this
gives us a total runtime and memory of
using the suffix tree of Big O of the
length of genome plus the combined
length of patterns and so I think I
offered a big improvement over what
Shawn was doing